et cyril m'a envoyé un texto maintenant
il veut savoir quel est cet autre au dos
cyril vous en voyez ça non là bas alors
là on notait il ya un autre dos non mais
j'ai pas faire de mal au furet dans le
chien fallut pas bête alors mais il est
là mon dos il en avait pas mais écoutez
moi je comprends qu'on soit amoureux non
pas quand même non blague à part
non non non ça y est je vous dirais le
jour où il y aura quelque chose de
sérieux
mais je connais déjà non absolument pas
on le connaît pas même si je vous dis le
prénom a fait pas des clubs désireux
comme on sait comment ça se passe et nom
et le prénom pas voir le prénom bah oui
s'appelle benjamin
[Musique]
ça m'arrange pas ce prénom pointait
alors à idées sinon qu'egide ah ben non
mais on a donc l âge est d'après vous
quel âge il a il a 29 ans parisien donc
si vous appelez benjamin vrai 29 ans
envoyez-nous busnel enquête ça nous
arrangera évidemment